[Musique]
il n'y a pas de traitement il n'y a pas de remède cela
transforme les humains en prédateurs violents
la communication est impossible sauf
pour moi
prêt je ne peux pas parler leur langue pourquoi
j'ai été mordu mais pas nous sommes
cachés sous terre dans un  silo nucléaire nous avons
désespérément cherché le patient zéro nous
ne pouvons pas procéder à l'ingénierie inverse d'un vaccin
sans le patient zéro la musique ne
l'affecte pas du tout rien
[Musique]
vous supposez que nous sommes tous pareils
quelque chose que vous et SMAW évoluez vous
savez quelque chose sur le patient zéro c'est
seulement  une question de temps, croyez-moi, à partir de ce
moment-là, c'est un luxe que vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre.
J'ai été purgé. J'ai l'air malade à vos yeux? Je
ne pense pas que nous soyons la maladie,
nous sommes le remède pour nous débarrasser de l'
infection humaine que nous  nous continuerons à nous battre contre
ces papas, ce que nous faisons,
je vous suggère de vous demander qui vous gagne
[Musique]
vous